un élu proche de ses administrés
accessible pour rester maire de joigny
bernard moraine compte avant tout sur
son bilan
il dit avoir unifié avec son équipe une
ville et des habitants qui ne se
parlaient plus mais aussi avoir géré
avec succès le départ du 28e groupe
géographique et ses militaires
on a réussi je crois pas c'est tout
c'est qu'à plat et maintenant on a fait
un travail peut-être qu'il s'est pas vu
les joviniens ont pas vu ce travail de
fond et maintenant on aimerait exploiter
et montrer tout ce qu'on a mis en place
montrer que maintenant on peut on peut
encore mieux améliorer la vie de chaque
jeu vignes en face à lui le maire
sortant a une fois encore une droite
divisée
françois jacq et le candidat de l'ump
sorti vainqueur d'une primaire organisée
par son parti
ce retraité jovinien veut en finir avec
la gestion socialiste de la conduire
avec ces retards et dépassements de
budget le chantier de la future
bibliothèque médiathèque en serait de
céréales c'est une méthode de gestion
qui n'est pas la nôtre mais qui est
celle du mode socialiste qu'on découvre
au niveau de la mairie de joigny au
niveau du
l'état au niveau de la région c'est
partout pareil on dépense plus qu'on
gagne ça n'est absolument pas de notre
façon de gérer
nous ce que nous souhaitons ce que nous
mettrons en oeuvre si nous sommes élus
c'est une rigueur dans la gestion ou on
n'a peut-être pas les mêmes moyens y en
a certains qui ont des partis derrière
nous on en a pas réunion de campagne au
domicile d'isabelle bourassin elle aussi
candidate pour la droite et joigny forte
de son expérience l'actuel conseil
municipal d'opposition se dit ambitieuse
pour sa ville mais surtout légitime à 54
entre la courtière en assurances a donc
décidé de repartir à la conquête de
l'hôtel de ville
on n'a pas pu s'entendre c'est comme ça
bon puisque vous voulez j'ai toujours
dit qu'on ne faisait pas boire un âne
qui n'avez pas soif
et qu'à partir du moment où les gens ne
veulent pas d'une association
ce n'est pas possible de faire autrement
c'est dommage puisque moi ma liste
précédente en 2009 s'appelait l'union de
joigny on a essayé de faire l'union mais
pas avec tout le monde
historiquement conservatrice pendant des
décennies jouanny n'avait basculer à
gauche qu'en raison d'une droite divisée
en 2008
le scrutin avait ensuite été annulée
mais un an plus tard lors de l'élection
partielle
la liste ps avait su en tirer profit
avec une victoire dès le premier tour et
plus de 65 % des voix